well the ring entities proved to be a
threat in the future what's the deal
with cara's resurrected brother here are
the biggest unanswered questions from
season six of the expanse
admiral duarte is first mentioned in the
final episode of season five when
admiral soviter congratulates marco on
behalf of duarte and informs him that
the laconia system is now under their
control for book readers this is a
tantalizing morsel as duarte is the
villain of the seventh and eighth
expanse novels although that story takes
place 30 years in the future and the
books the show indicates duarte has
already started down whatever path he
plans to take duarte is one of the
leaders of the rogue martian faction
that exchanges the martian's advanced
weapon technology with marco for a
sample of the proto molecule and the
proto-molecule expert dr paulo corteza
his choice to settle on laconia appears
to be strategic as at the end of season
5 an alien spacecraft is seen hovering
above the planet when duate finally
appears in the fourth episode of season
six he is interrupted at a funeral by
cortazar who arrives to inform him that
he's made contact with a dormant alien
craft presumably by using the
proto-molecule in the series finale
duate is shown looking up at the craft
and then later in the episode he brushes
off marco informing him you were a
useful distraction but i have gods to
kill while it's not clear what this
means duarte seems to have big plans
that involve using the proto-molecule to
gain power over alien technology
throughout season six the story of young
laconia girl cara gets more attention
than that of admiral duarte from the
first episode it's clear that kara
spends a great deal of her time with the
native wildlife of laconia and seems to
know all the species yet on a trip to
the forest she discovers a new animal
tentatively looking at her which she
labels a dog when one of the birds she
knows gets sick and dies the laconian
dog resurrects it and cara is elated to
have it back you fixed her
you fixed her you fixed it
surely afterward her younger brother zan
dies after being hit by a car not
wanting to lose her brother cara takes
xan's body to the laconian dogs in the
forest and after he's been resurrected
brings him back home instead of being
happy to see their son alive however
kyra's parents are terrified kiera's
father even brandishes a knife against
zan but a gas she inflicts on zan's hand
heals almost immediately realizing the
adults could take him away again kira
escapes into the forest with zan there
the show depicts the world from zan's
point of view a perspective filtered
through the blue lens of the
proto-molecule like others who have been
infected by the proto-molecule zam
retains some of his own memories but
he's not entirely himself either and
that means he has probably exceedingly
dangerous to everyone in laconia
starting with cara
in season six holden learns that some
ships went missing while passing through
the ringer gate it's like a hole
suddenly opens in the floor but if
someone falls in
they're gone holden suspects this is the
work of angry alien entities within the
ring that may be waking up because of
the humans now slipping through to
holden this is a bigger problem than
even the war between the inner planets
and marco not only does it mean that
some ships are vanishing without a trace
but it also means the whole system could
incur the wrath of the aliens that
eradicated the proto-molecules creators
holden's initial impulse is to tell
everyone about the problem including
marco but it turns out to be a good
thing that he doesn't
in the final battle with marco naomi and
the crew of the racinante use this
knowledge to their advantage notably
marco manages to defeat the inners and
is on the verge of victory but as he
approaches the ring the rossi pushes
anything they can through it in order to
reach the energy threshold that will
trigger the ringed entities ultimately
marco and his ship dematerialize as they
pass through the ring ending the humans
war however as holden observes this
could also wake the ring entities
permanently while things seem quiet in
the immediate aftermath of the battle
could the entities already be awake or
will something else trigger them leading
to even more problems than marco
in the last few moments of the series
finale it's revealed that philip doesn't
perish on the pellet with his father
marco as his mother naomi nagata
believes instead he takes a ship and
leaves the free navy before the pillar
gets to the ring in season 5 philip
reunites with naomi for the first time
since he was a toddler and although
naomi tries to rescue him from marco's
toxic influence philip ultimately
rejects naomi in favor of the father who
has always been there for him
everything my father told me about you
it's true
don't go phillip please
even though she mourned the loss of her
son naomi seems to have made her peace
with her choice not to sacrifice herself
for motherhood on the other hand meeting
naomi leaves philip remarkably
conflicted in the season's early
episodes this causes philip to act out
and rebel against his father later he
starts to realize that marco lies and
manipulates people including him to get
them to do what he wants by the time the
final battle arrives philip has grown so
disenchanted with marco that he finally
breaks free from his father and even
decides to take his mother's last name
this leads to the inevitable question of
whether mother and son will ever reunite
will philip search for naomi or will he
keep his distance making his way in the
universe on his own
while philip ends a series by rejecting
his father that doesn't mean marco's
influence doesn't loom large after all
he spent his entire childhood as a
member of marco's free navy surrounded
by people who believed in the belter
cause and marco's violent tactics in
fact in the sixth season's fourth
episode he loudly proclaims his loyalty
after kamina drummer a fellow belter
transmits a message announcing she's
reclaimed supplies marco took from
non-free navy belters in response philip
brands drummer an enemy and claims a
free navy must pursue their adversaries
without remorse or fear this
is war
and it won't be over until we are dead
or victorious philip is still young and
torn between the beliefs of his father
and his mother while his desertion of
the free navy indicates he's embraced
his mother's more nuanced and peaceful
way of thinking old habits die hard so
although it seems that the system may be
entering a time of relative peace philip
could still be swayed to join another
fraught cause and if he does which way
will he go will he look for unity and
common ground like his mother or will he
follow in his father's footsteps and
become a violent authoritarian
holden and the crew are all back on the
rossi including bobby draper the ship's
new pilot while they're enjoying a
period of relative quiet they still have
to decide on their next move and it goes
without saying that the rossi always
manages to become involved in universe
shattering events when holden and naomi
speak at the end of the episode holden
mentions they could become security for
freighters passing through the ring or
consultants on one of the ringed
colonies but he also brings up the fact
that they still haven't tracked down the
missing proto-molecule sample stolen
from fred johnson in the fifth season
this is a sample that admiral duarte
possesses on laconia and while holden
doesn't know this his concerns about
what's happened to the sample likely
loom large in his mind so while the
rashi crew has a number of options it
seems like sooner or later holden will
want to pursue the proto-molecule again
this would undoubtedly put him on a
collision course with duate and whatever
he's doing with the alien technology on
laconia although holden spent less time
dealing with the proto molecule over the
last two seasons of the expanse it seems
like this plotline could have become a
major part of his and the rasis story
once again had the show continued
perhaps it will sometime in the future
one of the outcomes of the war with
marco is that the belters gain a seat at
the negotiating table but that doesn't
mean everyone is happy to have them in a
position equal to earth and mars holden
used as a negotiations to maneuver
drummer into the position of president
of the newly formed transport union the
independent organization installed to
oversee transit through the ring as he
observed in the series finale this
upsets quite a few people
you duplicitous little that was the only
way the belters have historically been
oppressed by the inner planets and
despite recent progress a lot of
prejudice and suspicion still exists
between earth mars and the belt so the
question becomes will the inners
continue to share power with the belters
especially when the belt does now
control the transport union over the
course of the show christian of vasarala
the current un secretary general has not
only learned to see the value in working
together with others toward common goals
but she's also developed a much softer
stance toward belters however earth's
next leader may not share this position
especially given that marco abelta
devastates the planet of course both
earth and mars forces are greatly
depleted so it would be a challenge for
them to take on the belt now even if
they wanted to it's hard to say what
could happen in the future
amos burton brings clarissa mao holden's
one time wannabe assassin on board the
rosanante at the end of season five in
season six clarissa does her best to
redeem herself for her indiscretions and
eventually wins over holden and naomi
and becomes an accepted member of the
crew yet clarissa has been having health
problems ever since she used the
augmentations implanted in her body
early in the season so when she once
again feels sick during the series
finale she checks her health in the
medical bay and is diagnosed with
complex endocrine collapse syndrome a
condition with no approved treatment and
a life expectancy of only five years
given the battle the rasi is about to
engage in perhaps it's not surprising
that clarissa doesn't mention her
failing health to the crew before the
fight however though she stays on the
rashi following the conclusion of the
war it appears she continues to keep her
medical condition secret what will this
mean for clarissa moving forward she
still feels incredible remorse for the
life she took in pursuit of holden so
perhaps she feels she's getting what she
deserves but it's also possible clarissa
could find a doctor or experimental
treatment that could help her to extend
her life will she continue to suffer in
silence and accept her fate or will she
decide to fight for her life if you
don't like waiting and hoping for a
continuation of the series the books are
sitting on the shelves at the store
waiting to be read
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]